covering a half acre with hanging
flowers the oldest known wisteria in
japan is the centerpiece of this
brilliantly pastel colored flower park
[Music]
located in tochiki japan just over an
hour train ride from tokyo is ashikaga
flower park
the park spans 23 acres and is home to
more than 350 wisterias and other
flowers
the colors vary depending on the
flowering season from pinks and purples
to yellows and whites
some features of the park include the
wisteria tunnel and floating gardens but
the pride and joy of ashikaga flower
park is the great miracle wisteria
the 140 year old sprawling tree is
located in a place of pride right in the
center of the park
after nightfall the site is lit up so
these draping flowers can be seen at all
hours
the vivid yellow wisteria begins
blooming at the start of may and is the
only one of its kind in japan
the park is a year-round attraction with
seasonal plants that creates an
ever-changing sense of magnificence as
nature puts on a show
[Music]
[Music]
limoulan
is a curious place
very curious
and it all comes from the mind of a
clown
[Music]
you slava is an avant-garde performance
artist and one of the most recognizable
clowns in the world he grew up in
communist russia and spent his youth
idolizing charlie chaplin
slava revolutionized the art of clowning
moving it out of the circus and onto the
stage
[Music]
picnic the mulan john islav's creative
space where he and his family and his
academy of fools host open events run
workshops and rehearsals all in his
surreal wonderland
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
some people who come to this house it
looks like something out of a romantic
magical fairy tale but this romantic
magical fairy tale really is our home
i'm jasmine i'm simon and we live out in
the sully hills in west wales
[Music]
we're part of a wide community that
spreads over the whole region and the
local area of people learning to spread
softly on the earth
when we decided to settle down and make
a permanent home it seemed fairly clear
to us we much prefer to be in the
countryside
and i did like the sort of magical
element of you know the idea of fairies
and myths and stuff like that
we built a small simple modest house out
of the things that were around us out of
the things that we could easily get from
waste and from the natural world rather
than going and buying things
this is where we store our firewood to
keep us warm through the winter
it took us about two months so we've
used stones mud clay wood we brought in
some straw bales and used quite a lot of
those
and it cost us around about two or three
thousand pounds
and the big house um simon's finishing
it to a very high standard so it will
have a lot of longevity it will last for
a long time generations
and we are using recycled materials
natural materials or things that we've
grown available from this piece of land
this is my greenhouse
you put the food in relationship to the
house and to the water and to the
landscape and instantly income the
fellows the birds and the insects our
dirty water can feed the plants our need
for shelter can give nice shelter for
other animals to come and live and we
really can live in a way which is
sympathetic to the rest of what's going
on in nature
this is my workshop my commute to work
goes a bit like this out of the front
door dodging between the flowers and
maybe picking a few berries off the bush
on the way past for a little snack until
i get to my workshop
[Music]
at the end of every day i could sit back
and see the thing that we've made and
know where the pizza would have come
from and the first night in a house that
you've made with your own friends
with your own hands in exactly the way
you want it to be
is an absolutely magical one
nestled in the side of the euro
mountains the site a reversible destiny
in japan is an experience park where
guests encounter the unexpected
the park was designed by artists shusaku
arakawa and madeline jinns and consists
of sculptures pavilions and constantly
changing terrains
there is an intricate network of 148
paths and 24 types of plants that
emphasize the changing of the season
such as cherry blossoms in the
springtime and vibrant autumn leaves in
the fall
some of the attractions include the
critical resemblance house which has a
map of gifu prefecture a region of
central japan as a rooftop
and the reversible destiny office that
contains an uneven pastel colored maze
and a ceiling that mirrors the design of
the floor
visitors are encouraged to explore the
site with the mindset of a child
to climb be curious and discover
different visual perceptions
but because of slanting angles steep
hills and narrow pathways the site of
reversible destiny offers optional
helmets to ensure a safe excursion
[Music]
sword banking has always been an
esoteric endeavor
there's never been a great number of
people doing it
you have this transformation of raw
material
the alteration of nature
and in the end you get something that
just exudes
power
[Music]
this is valyrian steel
it's my father's sword
the ancient swords on game of thrones
forged with valerian steel were stronger
and lighter than any other weapon
no one knows how they were made
in the real world over a thousand years
ago in viking lands there was also a
series of special swords with mysterious
origins
and a blacksmith in wisconsin tried to
make one
this is an olf bird sword
from about 850 to maybe early 1200s
in viking controlled lands you had a
sword that had a name inlay called
wolfbert
which roughly translates to a wolf tooth
or wolf bear
it's a word of power
[Music]
there are only 350 known alfred swords
forged with the quality of steel that
didn't emerge in europe for another
thousand years no one knows exactly how
they were made
i think i've come fairly close or at
least a pretty good rendition of how
they made those blades
steel is a pretty special material we
know a great deal about it and we know
almost nothing about it
so with the ulfbert you have a mythical
steel mirrored in the game of thrones
where you have this steel that no one's
able to reproduce that black valerian
steel
sword making technology still holds a
bit of alchemy a bit of mysticism in it
we want to believe that there's
something
that we can't understand
there's still mysteries in steel
[Music]
reaching up towards the sky these 3 000
pillars stand tall from the valley below
to make a towering forest of sandstone
[Music]
the zhang jiajie national forest park is
located in the west hunan province of
china and is over 600 miles away from
the major cities of shanghai and beijing
[Music]
fans of james cameron's avatar may find
these rock pillars familiar they were
the inspiration behind the mythical
world of pandora in the film
these pillars resulted from weather over
many years a combination of the changing
seasons and the plants that grow on them
have contributed to their individual and
unique shapes
although the seasons change the weather
is moist all year round which results in
dense foliage in fact 98 of the park is
covered in vegetation
there are hiking trails available to see
this incredible forest however as james
cameron knows nothing compares to
experiencing it from the sky
[Music]
[Music]
you